Thank you.
well i can't
just say it's the universe we don't want like english too
order order welcome jokies to 808 jokie verse council
meeting committee is now in session business.
As you know, we have received complaints from the other
Doki's that we do not have enough representation on the
board.
Ever since more and more Doki members have joined the DBA,
as you guys all know, the Doki Bird Association, we have to
nominate new delegates to represent our fellow Doki's.
But before we begin, let's do a roll call because last time
we didn't do a roll call and And then we didn't get enough
votes to pass our agenda.
So, first one on the list.
Grokey.
All right.
Doki bug.
Cha.
Mm-hmm.
Retro Doki.
Lay it again.
Present, present.
Oh,
he's five minutes from the fucking boardroom.
You can literally just attend the meeting in person.
Hey, who talked to me like that?
I used to be Doki.
Not even the original Doki Prime.
Yeah, but she's.
dead now.
So that makes me
Decorum dokeys.
Decorum!
Now, my fellow dokeys, we all know that without me, none of
you would exist.
So remember the mantra, guys.
And every dokey is a tomato.
They say tomato.
Tomato dokey is right.
At this moment, we need to deal with the current issues on
hand.
Yeah, if you knew it right.
And, as you all know, we have chosen representatives of all
different kinds of dokeys in the dokey.
first, but yet we still lack one important doki, a chibi
doki.
Tokis are talking.
Okay, who brought their chibi to the meeting today?
You know we can't bring outsiders?
Ah, sorry.
That's me.
I have custody of her today, and you know, her mom said I
don't pick her up.
I have to show up to her birthday.
No, we don't really do that.
You know us Doki's.
Okay, okay.
But if this happens again, just drop her off at Club Doki.
That's down the street.
They have a babysitting program there.
And they accept Chibi's as well, I think.
I'm pretty sure, right?
Hey!
Okay, for now, you can put her outside the door and put in a
box or something.
She can entertain herself for hours in there.
I've tried it with my TV.
Oh, anyway, back to my point.
The other jokies have started to accuse us of being chibis
because of our lack of representation.
And we can't have that again.
Not again, okay, guys?
Yep, we might hate mutants and raccoons, but we are not
chibis.
So, starting today, we have gathered a bunch of chibis.
Doki's, who applied for an interview to become the newest
board member of the Doki Council.
After the interviews, we will then have a vote with a board
on who was set at the table, you know, the usual stuff.
Yes, Doki, what is it?
Come on, Doki's.
Why don't we make it a little bit more exciting?
Also, well, I mean, we can get the drag rooms to vote for
the representative.
The first public Doki vote.
I'm looking at Twitter right now.
And look at the odd engagement baiting we can get.
We might even get another Hunger Games out of here.
babe you think about it yeah i mean they're still yelling
that the votes were rigged because i got in the board
instead of do kitty i'll make the rules there can only be
one cat on the council and what can i say it happened to be
the better cat honestly it's not a bad idea dokey all right
all in favor of letting the dragons decide to dokey
representative so we don't have to do more work
Okay, well, that seems to be everything on the agenda.
Um, looking at this, we do have the 3D debut and rest of
Tuber, but we can just table that for next year.
We gotta go home early and do our nap gotcha, right?
Like, it's our scheduled nap gotcha time.
We keep pushing into the next meeting, but I don't worry.
I'm pretty sure we'll get to it next meeting for sure this
time.
Finally tackle that shit.
I believe in us.
All right, all right, all right, all right, all right,
Jokies.
Meeting adjourned.
Go back to your Jokieverse.
Hello!
Hello, everyone!
Sorry, sorry, is my mic picking up?
Oh, there we go.
Sorry.
Sorry, these, like, new frangled mics that clips on your
collar.
Oh, my gosh.
Sometimes it just doesn't work that way, you know?
But welcome, dragons, to the historic DBA Maple Building,
named after one of our first founders, Maple Sea Bird.
So, guys, might be watching this wondering what's going on
here why are you gathered here well that means you haven't
seen our local dbn news so as announced on our official
network dbn you have all been gathered here for the very
first public dokey council election the first of its kind
open to all you dragoons yes you guys will finally have a
voice here in the dokey council of the dokey dba Adokie Bird
Association.
I shall be your assistant today.
Here to guide you throughout this process.
Because I fucked up.
So now they demoted me here to talk to you guys.
Yep.
Fucked up the coffee order.
No, they said being an intern would be fun, you know?
Being an intern to the DBA.
It would be so fun.
I fucked up one coffee order.
Now I'm here.
this interview process anyway so how this is gonna work well
the applicants as you guys can see right here right here
there's the glass room right here they're gonna walk into
this room and you dragoons can ask them any questions
through this speaker where a fellow dragoon will relate to
the doki that they are interviewing they will also give you
a resume oh let me pull up like this so they will also
provide you all resume so you can look through their
qualifications and credentials to see if they will be fit to
be on the board after all the interviews are done we'll then
have a public anonymous vote where the winner will be
announced right after and they will become the chibi
represented rip that out sorry i need my coffee i do the
coffee orders but i don't get i they don't even pay for my
coffee i gotta pay for my own coffee anyway they will become
the chibi representative but cheap sorry look i'm trying
here the chibi representative of the dokees in the dokeverse
now for some of you guys who are wondering how many
applicants or made dokeys are we going to be interviewing
today?
I've unfortunately lost that sheet of paper so I don't even
remember.
So we'll know when it ends.
When the chibi dokeys stop appearing, we'll know it ended.
That's our guideline.
Yeah.
Please remember if you take any of the dokeys' and rig the
vote your dokey will be suspended from the DBA and you know
she needs this so you don't want that to happen to your
dokey dragons understand so there's gonna be no rigging here
for this election any questions all right out of you don't
you don't have the right to vote anymore get out no matter
what the dokey's are ranked higher than the dragoons despite
whichever despite whatever dokey you're proud of i still
outrank you kick this dragoon out get out mr maflami i am
still in charge of this board of this
interview patra said thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you thank you for donating to DBA we need all these
donations for the upkeep of this organization there's a lot
of dokees working here non-stop for you guys uh but what if
I take prize from all of them one joy thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you that is a good question um
technically you can I mean you're gonna take a prize you can
might as well take it from all the But do not take a brat
from one Doki.
Take a brat from all the Doki's.
But if you take a brat from all of them, but what?
Your Doki will be suspended from the DBA.
All right, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This is not a bribed trust, but thank you for the super
chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Democracy was immediately broken.
No, no, no.
We appreciate your votes here.
Like I said, This is the very first public vote open to the
Dragoons.
Every decision in the past was decided by your fellow
Jokies.
But for today, we are hosting a very special event.
Today, your voice will now matter.
I don't know.
And, but if you fuck up this vote, it might not matter
later.
Just a little disclaimer.
This is a test.
you just so you guys know labor thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you asking us to choose just one is so cruel
when when they're all gonna be peaked thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you look just so you guys know
this is they're just gonna be the chibi representative of
the doki chibbies in the all the doki verse they'll still be
alive the other ones that do not get the board they still
exist for those who didn't know i we know that you guys have
complained in the past that do kitty should have been the
cat representative for the dokey cat board of councils but
but dokefield did win the vote in the majority vote of the
council and they are the cat representative so they still
exist they can coexist it's just we only have one
representative in the dokeyverse it is not rigged guys well
this is that well those the board votes are behind closed
doors we cannot release we cannot release the results on
that that is a private matter that dragoons do not have
jurisdiction to access we apologize but luckily for this you
also still to the results but but you get to vote for it we
will just a disclaimer we will not be releasing the results
of the vote but but but your voice matters your your voice
still matters uh christian thank you super chat thank you
thank you release the don't you I was and for we have
released it unfortunately um unfortunately it if there might
not be any text on it but you know it's not for your eyes
guys it's not for you guys all right are there any more
questions are you guys ready for the interview
are you guys ready
no more questions No, you guys do not get coffee.
I hope you guys went to the...
I hope you guys had your bathroom break, your food break,
and your water break because you're stuck in this room.
You will not be leaving until the vote is done.
Until the interviews and the vote is done.
Yes?
Alright, let me...
Let me go and turn off the lights real quick.
Do you guys like that music we have for this room?
It's also in the other room.
as well.
It's in the entire building.
So I hope you're okay with listening to this music on loop
for the rest of your day.
Click.
Alright.
So you guys can see it better, you know?
Give me a sec.
We gotta call in the doki real quick to let them know that
they are, they will be next.
Alright.
Let us now call the doki in.
What do you mean this is worse than jury duty.
You have, you get to vote for your representative.
Guys, remember to vote.
Oh, keep, oh, hey guys.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Keep placing happy birthday.
Sorry, happy birthday for Doug.
Of course.
I won't be on the screen.
I hope that's okay.
I'm too lazy to walk five steps forward.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you Happy birthday dear hey Dear dog Happy
birthday to you Yay birthday's dog Okay look Look how this
we will request one of the Joki Chibis to wish you a happy
birthday How about that That's our compromise We fucked up
there I fucked up there I will make sure one of the Joki
Chibis will wish you a happy birthday as well All right, all
right, let's go into the room now.
Enough, enough dilly-dallying.
We're gonna go get, go call in the first jokie.
Hey.
Hello.
Um, I think I need a little booster seat.
I don't think, uh, these chairs are made for, uh, our kind.
But, but if you vote for me, I will change that I will make
sure no matter how small the dokees are we we will be able
to fit the chairs all right I need I need some up these real
quick guys I give me a sec
wow oh hi okay I all right well I need to be a little higher
but that's okay I I
Alright Give me a sec Alright there you go Hello Um I'm Doki
Bird Um So I heard You know the The council of Doki's At the
DBA Or finally opening Um Uh Applications Uh For us chibi
doki's not that one but you know you know the other us you
know i know everyone's like oh chibi doki where's our voice
you know we exist too and that's why i wanted to apply so
that so that i can be a perfect representative of all the
doki chibis out there and my first order of business i will
give us booster seats so that we can look at you eye to eye
without us having to be like all right i need like a couple
of books here so i can actually like you know fit okay give
me a sec let me uh boost myself up ah there we go Anyway,
oh, yes, yes.
Oh, my resume.
Resume.
Yes, yes, here.
Here, here's my resume.
Please look.
I worked really hard on it.
So please look at my resume.
Come on, pull it up.
I worked really hard on this.
Wait, is this the...
Yeah, this is my...
Yeah!
As you see, my name is...
Dokibert.
My type is Gibi.
I am from C113 Dokiverse.
I'm very creative and detail-oriented, graphic designers
skilled in branding, digital illustration, typography, and
UI slash UX design.
I'm dedicated to creating impactful visuals that enhance
brand identity and user engagement.
Also, look at me, move.
Did you like that?
Did you guys like that?
That was pretty neat, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, did you see those moves?
Oh, wait, wait.
I got an idea.
Okay.
It's because, like...
Look, okay, um, wait, let me, uh, don't worry, I got this.
I'll, let me put it on the table.
There you go.
There we go.
Yeah, yeah, baby.
Yeah, let me, you like that?
All right, anyway, okay, oh yeah, yeah, my resume.
Let me, oh, let me.
grab my resume again okay here you go um skills i can become
do kitty so you know how you know how you know the
controversy that um that do kitty didn't get into the board
well if you if you elect me dragons i can be a fellow do
kitty watch this
Almost the same.
Yeah?
Wow!
I'm practically her.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, and also, I can be evil too.
I can be evil, dookitty too, if you want.
Yeah.
Oh yeah, also.
See, I'm very expressive too.
Oh, oh, and
so if you, if you vote for identity theft is a crime, um,
it's called parody law, um, I wouldn't expect you, Dragoon,
to know that, just you specifically, that Dragoon that said
that, all you other dragons, oh my god, my first
controversy, oh, don't cancel me, all you other triggers are
cool, you're cool in my book, but that Dragoon, that
Dragoon, he implied, he, tried to imply that i'm trying to
steal someone's identity i would never it's called like
parody law and it's called inspiration all right inspirate
fair use and in i was inspired by my idol dope kitty and i
felt that she deserved to be on the board okay um and
because you know they don't
get on the board you literally get tenors tenure so like you
cannot like they're there forever so dope kitty is never
gonna be able to get on the board but if you if you vote for
me we will have a dope kitty on the board just think about
that you know just just think about that also all right i
Don't you want to vote for me, please?
This is all I have.
I don't have a job.
They play really good bonuses at the boardroom.
Please vote for me.
I'm the first one to do it.
I have to be first for the interview.
So yes, a vote for me.
is a vote for Do-Kiri.
Also, I realized the intern did not mention this since we
also have like a speaker to your room as well so we could
hear what's going on in that room.
But they forgot to mention that you will be in charge of
naming, giving us the nicknames because, you know, we all
call each other Do-Ki-Bird, you know, like, oh, Do-Ki,
Do-Ki.
But like the names that you're more familiar with were given
by you guys.
Because, you know, like, for example, Kroki and Do Kitty,
they were like, you know, you guys gave their names.
So this is your job to, like, name each one of us, too.
So, you can't name me Do Cheeby because there's multiple
applicants to be...
There's multiple Cheebies coming in after me, guys.
I can't... I could be...
I could be Doe Cheeby Prime if you guys want that.
I'm not even the first one done too Oh she's gonna be so
pissed if I get Cheeby Prime I wasn't even the first Cheeby
like that debut too She's gonna be so mad
So what else What else can I show you guys Oh I could take
this off Look see I could put on my glass my aviators And
also um my jacket oh whoa you see that wow oh it's getting
hot in here dragons
oh scandas she's showing neck it's not a bribe guys i'm just
showing you guys all the different things i can do with my
skin suit guys i this is it's not a bribe don't guys guys
don't tell the the intern that's not a bribe yes it's Not a
bribe.
And as always, like all, like all dokees, we also have our
own dads too.
See?
We have dad here too.
Look.
We have dad.
No, don't tell the council.
Don't tell the, I didn't bribe you guys.
Guys, I didn't, I was just, oh, it's so hard in here, guys.
It's so...
so yes i also have um i also have dad here as well anyway um
what else was on my resume i know i just i sort of wrote
this resume like 30 minutes before the interview started so
give me a sec i'm selling you on this right oh yeah i can
succeed the nap gacha that's why i'm always look like i look
like i have like so much energy because i never every time i
take the nap gacha it always unlocked my true potential um
and uh and like i'm never tired guess why my eyes are like
full of hope and happiness it has not like unlike the other
dokees um the light is still in my eye the light still
shines uh and finally next see thank you let's see for
chatting that no No, no, no, no, don't make that my nick.
There's still other applicants, guys.
There's still other applicants, please.
You haven't even met them yet, guys.
You haven't even met them.
All right, and finally, I am the skater boy.
Unfortunately, I didn't bring my outfit today.
But, but I took a photo of it.
All right, I have a photo.
Wait, give me a sec.
Let me find the photo.
Let me find it.
I saved it on my phone somewhere, guys.
Guys, give me it.
Let me see.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, I take a lot of photos, okay?
Like, you know, we all have all dokees.
All dokees have dad.
So, like, you know, my phone is just filled with dad photos.
But I swear, I can be a skater boy.
Look, look, look.
I am a skater boy.
Look at that.
I forgot to bring my outfit.
Look, see?
I come, I come with skater, skates.
So, do I have your road, Dragoon?
See, she was a skater boy.
She said, see you later, boy.
Not only can I be your dog kitty, I can also be your skater
boy.
So, do I get your vote dragon to be the next board member of
the Doki Council?
Yeah?
Any questions you would like to ask me?
get an airport ninja thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you nah teal's off we like our oh she's more depressed
than we are but i can be your skater boy thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you she's my everything that nice i'm glad
you guys pledge your allegiance to me without seeing what
the other jokies look like that's good that's good i like
that how short are you we are average chibi size in fact
some might say we are above average okay
we'll call you we'll call you when we're
later.
That's good sign, right, guys?
That's good, right?
Short of any crows or dragons, you've got my vote.
Lord Kurosus, they give a super chat.
Thank you.
Men, they give a super chat.
Why buy booster seats to be eye-level the others when that
costs money, taking the other doki shins away?
That is true.
If you vote for me, I will unite all the above average.
dragoons and dokies um to like break all the other all the
tall all the tall dragoons and dokies ankles so then they'll
have to they'll be forced to like squat down
next seat thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
above average like what eight inches tall um i don't think i
want to disclose my height right now that is personal
information and was told that you cannot ask that question
because um that's a breach of my personal information and my
privacy and my lawyer my lawyer will not be happy about that
that is very rude you never ask a doki chibi what her height
is that is very rude you lost my boat wait wait i can get it
back i can get your vote back
do i get your vote back did that did i get it back did i end
up next well fine fine then
finally oh my god oh my god i'm so short i mean i'm so above
average i am so above average height right now I'm leaving
sorry um I popped the champagne accidentally because I was I
was celebrating early
all right give me a sec I have to call the intern in every
time we have to call the intern in every time we leave so
give us give us a sec right now I think the intern went to
get again i think yeah i think the intern went to grab
coffee don't wait don't wait she's coming back guys she's
coming back
all right sorry i went to grab coffee what the you mean
immersion look guys there's a lot of stuff we have to do
here at the dba okay
It is a lot of work, okay, because it is All the other
dokees, I just want you guys to know The building is,
there's only like three staff members in the building right
now All the other dokees are doing their nap, gotcha, okay,
guys Like it's literally me and two other dokees fucking
trying to do this The other dokees went and do their nap,
gotcha So I'm, me and the other two have to man the ship at
the moment All right, so what did you guys think of
candidate?
Candidate number one, Dragoons.
What did you think?
Me?
She was pretty solid.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't know.
Skater boy.
She doesn't seem very committed.
Oh, it's a little 50-50 there.
But don't worry.
We have lots of candidates for you, guys.
Good, but we need to see.
Yeah, that is only...
That is only Doki Chibi number one.
We still have plenty of candidates for you guys to look and
interview.
Good first round.
Oh, good first round invite the second.
Lavi, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
I wouldn't touch C1, 1, 3 with an infinity feet long ball.
What did you not like about her?
For those who didn't, who didn't, for those that didn't win
your vote, why didn't, why didn't you want to vote for her,
guys?
She wrote her resume with G Chat GPT.
I can't tell.
Attitude.
Very cute.
I'm sure you, she will pull, well, airport.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
She was too bright of a soul.
Too much like Tom Doki.
All right.
Well, I guess let's go bring in the second Doki Chibi and
see how she pulls.
See if she wins your vote.
All right.
I'm just going to go get her now.
You see why the stream was delayed.
Now you know.
Alright.
Pulling.
Trying to find.
They're very tiny.
So it's very hard to find them.
Okay guys.
They're very very tiny.
It takes a while to find these dookies.
Bada-dada-dab-dab-dab-dab-dab-dab.
Sorry, I always hum when I'm, like, trying to find them.
All right.
All right, let's go to the room now.
Well, I guess it's my turn, isn't it?
All right.
Alright, let's get this over with.
No, it's not dad.
I mean, dad's here too.
But, like, it's not dad.
No, no.
I'm my own person.
These goddamn short...
This is...
The accessibility of this building sucks.
They do not care about us.
I mean, look how tiny these...
I mean, look how big these chairs are.
are where is the accessibility here in this building oh my
god you know not only do they not have ramps but they do not
have bigger chairs for us
oh my god all right i just need up these hello can you see
me now oh my gosh it's okay it's okay
Don't worry, I got this Hey Sup, bro Sup,
yeah Um So, like I only applied Because They said that you
get like, you get like bonuses if you make it to the board.
And like, I love free stuff.
So I was like, fuck, might as well try, you know?
I mean, like, free is free.
And don't you like free stuff too i mean let me let me let
me what's up bro
yeah i'm dokey braid i mean to be fair we're all dokey braid
and you know oh you want to see my kicks bro okay look look
if you vote for me bro let me tell you this Okay, wait, let
me get on this table real quick.
All right, okay, look at these kicks though.
Like, if you vote for me, look at these sick-ass kicks, you
too can be, like, as stylish as me.
Like, think about that.
Yeah, like, bro, look at these.
Come on.
Don't look at these shoes, man.
They cost a lot of money.
Come on.
say yeah thank you for the akasupa thank you thank you take
my money thank you with it I mean those go hard don't they
bro yeah this trip goes fucking hard
all right so yeah oh yeah oh yeah my resume okay let me uh
let me grab my resume real quick where is it where did it I
put my resume oh here it is here all right you can look at
my resume too if you want I worked very hard on it too um I
worked insanely hard on this uh when I heard that they're
looking for a you know for a dokey chippy representative uh
for the board and I was just like I mean I gotta try hard
I've never tried this hard before my life so let me show you
oh oh you grab it did you grab the resume all right look at
this look at this shit all right so as you know I'm dokey
bird as always like we're all dokey birds my type chibi um
you know about me bros before hoes you know you dig bro
you dig anyway so my dokey purse is uh see 1983 um and And
my professional, my professional skills, um, really good at
sleeping.
Um, oh, okay, I'll show you guys how good I'm sleeping I am
later.
But, um, I always swallow my bubble gum.
Like, here, watch this.
I swallowed it.
That's pretty sick, isn't it?
Yo, that's pretty cool, wasn't it?
Wait, I'll do it again.
Oh,
yeah, bro, okay.
Oh, my, okay, wait.
Let me take my hood down.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Also, you know, like, bro, I'm sick of all these posers.
I'm so sick of all these posers.
All these dokey posers who can't even unlock a dokey's
true...
for him.
I can do that.
I ain't no fucking poser.
Watch this.
Watch this, guys.
Yeah.
See?
I come from a pure bloodline of dokees.
You know?
A fucking course I can do that.
That's when you know I'm the real dokees.
I'm Might as well be Doki Chibi Prime.
Because I can do that.
But yeah.
How's that sound, Dragon?
A vote for me.
Is a vote for a bro.
Astro, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
How can we choose between these Doki's?
It's not fair.
oh yeah so all right so the sleeping part i'll i'll get to
that at the end okay that oh that's that's that's gonna be
like what's gonna secure my vote you know that i'm saving
that for last that's my trump card all right so other than
that my personal skills are you know marketing strategy
accounting communication i mean all jokies are really bad at
math but like i'm like you gotta do it one of the doki's had
to do it you know this is my like side gig you know
accounting like might not be like fully right but you know
i'm trying you know i gotta make ends meet you know like to
afford these sick drips like bam like boom
um technical stuff communication bro you know i'm good at
communication bro and problem solving and finally aura farm
I mean look at this look at this I'll show you wait give me
a sec look at this though I'll show you how how much I can
aura farm
yeah yeah that was aura wasn't it yeah there's aura right
there i don't i don't
so i don't i'm so cool guys no oh my god stop i know i'm
cool well yeah i know i'm cool oh yeah okay so i have a lot
to go through i actually have a lot i I don't know if I can.
I'll do like, we have like limited time for each candidate.
So I'll go, I'll do like a speed run.
Nah.
This is when, this is when I get, when I'm able to like get
my sick drip, you know, at the store, you know, after lining
up for like five hours and I got my Nike shoes.
And then that's why I'm content.
I'm like, today's a lazy day.
It is.
today is a today's not a lazy day right now but you know i'm
giving you an example bro i'm giving you an example right
now and then uh i guess you know when i'm doing my sick
lines you know my sick verse you know and there's like a rap
battle here on i'm like but i'm i'm like mary had a little
lamb little lamb little lamb mary had a fucking little lamb
bro that that song goes so hard.
I already forgot the lyrics at the end.
I mean, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Awesome.
Yeah.
You gonna vote for me, bro?
Because it'll be a shame if something happens to you later.
That's what.
Wow!
What?
You're gonna vote for me?
Oh, and...
Oh my god!
Yeah, MM got real quiet after that track dropped.
And then...
Okay, I don't know.
Sorry, sometimes my face does this.
And don't worry, it's okay.
But also...
When I find out that someone stepped on my shoe, you know?
I get real sad.
You know?
Don't you fucking hate that, bro?
When they like step on your shoe?
It's like a $1,000 shoe.
And, yeah!
Yeah!
I told you, and
I told you, there's a lot I could do, okay?
Like, my face is magical, bro.
So, what did I say?
I got even more!
I need a note.
I need a note, bro.
If you want me, you want to see more?
I mean, the first one's free.
But after that, you gotta pay up, bro.
So, so, do I got your vote, then?
You want to see more?
You want to see more, don't you?
I have a lot more to show you.
I haven't even shown you about my sleeping skills yet.
But I need to know.
You gonna vote for me?
You gonna vote for me, bro?
Yeah?
Excellent cat.
Ah, shucks.
I know.
I'm excellent.
I'm so cool.
Not yet, bro.
Bro, come on.
I showed you my face.
Please vote.
All right, all right, all right.
And then, oh my gosh, I'm so nervous.
This is my first time actually doing something like this,
you know, like, oh my gosh, it's so hard being so serious
all throws off the vibe too and then you know when um you
know don't you hate it whenever your fucking soul just comes
out of your body
that fucking sucks man whenever your soul just tries to
leave your your meat here your skin suit oh yeah that for
that's like fucking sucks also whoa and then when i see my
favorite Oh my god, when I see that Fortnite updated, you
know, I collect shoes from any types of games, you know,
any, whether digital or real life.
So whenever Fortnite updates to the shop, and then like,
there's new shoes in the shop, and I'm like, oh my god, bro,
they added, they added Aria shoes, they added, oh my god,
they added new kicks, bro.
New Fortnite update?
I don't remember what this is.
Oh, wait.
And now I get so tired.
Oh, sorry.
Whoa.
Sorry.
That was one of my sleeping skills.
That was one of my...
Oh, yeah.
By the way, um, my hair...
So, like, you know how, like, each dokey has their little...
Their little bird wings, you know?
Watch this.
This is my special skill, too.
Yeah.
Can any of the other dokeys do this?
Oh, wait.
Whoa.
And then you can, I can unburden my dokeys too.
Yeah, that's right.
Four wings.
That's right.
I am truly the ultimate life form.
I am the ultimate life form.
but i can also i guess go to default too but i don't know i
think this fits me i think i look sick as hell you know
obviously i could do this i can just put on the default wig
you know this is my real hairstyle but you know i could put
on the wig if you guys want i don't if you're you want you
You want Doki?
You want Doki to recognize?
I don't get...
No, I can't, unfortunately...
I can't turn into a cat.
But...
You want to see my special skill?
I bought...
Huh?
I have a special skill, guys.
You want to see?
Look, I can bring it back.
I'm really good at sleeping.
Watch this.
Don't, don't, don't, don't swipe right, left, wait, it's
left or right, I, Bro, too busy, fine shoes, bro, I, wait,
don't end call, don't take call, I'm not done yet, I'm not
done, I'm not to watch this, bam, bam, that's right, and
the map, sleeper that's fucking right you know remember I
heard that I heard that other dokey what an amateur didn't
forgot you to even bring her clothes her her skater boy
clothes I didn't forget look at this that's right I heard
you dragoons really like good night dragoons a vote for me
means more good night dragoons think about it yeah Yeah.
I got a sleep trip all readied up, right?
I'm dressed for the job.
Exactly.
Imagine, if you vote for me to be the next Chibi
representative, I will pass a new order to demand more good
night dragoons.
Of course, I will be leading it.
I mean, I'm already dressed for the job, you know?
I...
Genesis, they give a super chat, they give thank you.
But I'm already dressed for the job.
More good night dragoons means happier dragoons.
So what do you think?
I mean, I don't think the other dokees are gonna...
I don't think the other dokees are gonna fight for that.
Obviously.
And watch this.
You can sleep anywhere.
Oh, oh, oh my god.
Okay.
I'm okay.
That's again.
I got this.
All right.
So, what do you guys think?
Any questions?
What questions do you guys have for me?
Yeah, I'm sleep maxing.
I'm aura farming.
Look, see?
Watch this.
Yeah.
Bam.
Oral farm.
Yeah.
what is my biggest weakness that i care too much i'm too
passionate bro you know i'm just oh don't you hate it when
you're just too passionate man i fucking hate that shit
Any other questions that you have for me?
Yeah, I work too hard.
Damn right.
Laughy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What do you mean, break?
Guys, don't you want to ask me any?
You want to know more about me, guys?
What do you mean, neck?
Bro, I showed you.
I showed you my strip.
I brought...
How come you ask the elder candidate more questions than me?
I brought the outfit.
She did it.
I showed you my drip.
Please respond.
God.
I can't believe it.
Don't appreciate peek when it's in front of you
I'm calling in the intern now I think she's gone again I
think the Earth's intern I think the intern went to Club
Dokey To grab some drinks real quick Give me a sec Just
trying to get her back in
She'll be back guys She'll be back Don't worry We still have
Lots of candidates left to go.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
I'm back.
I'm back, guys.
Sorry.
I'm not.
I'm sober.
To be fair, don't go to Club Doki today.
That place overrun by, you know, the Chibi Doki's.
Not a good time to be there at the moment.
So, what did you guys think?
A Doki Chibi number two?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
If I vote for you, will you make that sleeping mask a merch?
Wait, no, come back.
Well, you and me.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Well, lucky for you.
It's already a merch item, but it's sold out right now.
It's out of stock, but maybe we'll bring it back in the
future.
You know, brokeeper, it has it.
Maybe some dragons actually, actually, um, have.
the sleeping mask too right now in person yeah
got his hopes up she's a good candidate so far oh that's
good to know that's good to know who's gonna vote for him
what what do you guys want called brokey bird who wants to
vote for brokey bird here hands up here who has won their
vote out of 10?
Oh, that's good to know.
Yeah, she seems to be such a bro right now.
I'll vote for both.
Well, you can only vote for one.
You can only, unfortunately, you can only vote for one.
Who isn't gonna vote for Prokey Bird?
Why?
What are your reasons?
Why did she not win your vote?
very cute i'm sure she will pull well did you not say that
about the first one too airport ninja thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you
her jordans are fake whoa don't say that in front of her
she's gonna get very mad about that
please don't make me choose unfortunately you will have to
pick like i said it is it you guys have to think it is an
honor to be able to vote for the next uh for the next doki
council member you are part of history right now dragons
actual history all right are you guys ready for the next
candidate
an honor and a privilege exactly are you guys ready no
questions here next candidate all right let me go bring her
in then we'll go to club doki again i gotta get some drinks
hello oh wait wait sorry sorry oh i have my filter on sorry
hey yo oh wait oh my filter was was was on already oh okay
sorry sorry oh my god these these god i swear to god i i
keep sending them like complaints you know that like i feel
like the official buildings of the dba they're like they
don't
they just they just don't care you know they got it at least
i have to that's okay i might need a piece i might need a
piece as well all right don't worry ah hello hello whoa whoa
whoa what do you mean wrong wrong category wrong position
hello i am the best of both worlds yeah i wait wait me i am
not only chibi i'm also pixel chibi yeah
doesn't that give you so much nostalgia yeah look at this
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa yeah i could do a little
shimmy shimmy to the left shimmy to the right a shimmy
shimmy shimmy shimmy i hold 24 bit look at that
Yeah, aren't you feeling nostalgic right now?
Remember those times when you boot up your Game Boy Color or
your Game Boy Advance and you played all these nostalgic
games or PlayStation 1 and PlayStation 2 and GameCube?
Oh, don't I just give you so much nostalgia for the good old
days when games look just like me?
You remember?
you're right you're reading this the sega genesis and like
oh you know i look like all your favorite games remember
when pokemon was pixelated you remember do you remember and
then also but then also current gen games also the games
where i remind you of like stardew valley Terraria, all
those comfy games.
Do you remember?
Sajian, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Do you remember when Pokemon was good?
When did he look like me?
Do you remember?
Oh, I remember.
yeah so dragon a vote for me is a vote for nostalgia and
then like you know i can influence you know the doki king
choices don't you want her to play all these nostalgic games
you know on stream just think about it all those games that
remind you oh don't you want her to play the first sonic you
know don't you want to play that the first sonic looks like
me too do you remember do you
yeah Jordan thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
thank you here's the 900k more congrats turkey nothing can
stop us at all thank you the super chat thank you thank you
And then, remember like, there's Pokemon Mystery Dungeon,
the first ones before they went 3D, you know?
Do you remember that?
Before they went 3D?
Those are good times, weren't they?
Now imagine, now imagine if Adoki plays that on stream for
you, plays all these nostalgic and retro games.
Do I remember?
She's got me guys.
So do I have your vote?
I remember.
Oh yeah, oh yeah, my resume, sorry, sorry, I just, you know,
just going through memory lane, you know, with you, and
remembering all those nostalgic times together that just
slipped my mind.
Oh wait, I got my resume here, don't worry, there you go.
Just as they give the super chat, thank you, thank you.
All right, all right, all right, don't worry, I got the
resume right here, right here for you.
All right, you can pull it up on your side now.
Here you go.
I know.
That's me.
Yeah, that's me.
So, I am.
My name's Doki Bird.
Well, we're all Doki Birds.
And, not only...
I'm not only am I Chibi, but I'm also PIXA!
vote for me i will represent not only the chibi community
the chibi community of the dokees but also the pixel and
retro dokees of the community and don't you want to remember
the good old times you know that's what games are escapisms
you know don't you want to just remember the good old times
when you played all those games when games were good back
then do you remember
and um so wait let me see if there's anything else at the
bottom no okay all right so um my dokeyverse my dokeyverse i
mean those are good times no i'm not falling for it don't
you want to remember thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you we're running around with sheep back then too
weren't those times so good and there was no ai and we're
all just look at us we We're all drawn by human hands, too.
Oh my god.
Anyway, my joke, I am from, my jokieverse is PC151.
That is my jokieverse number.
And I'm very good at yelling.
Look.
Look at this.
Don't worry.
I can show you how good I am at yelling.
Hello!
Do you remember?
Yeah, you remember, right?
No, I don't remember.
Also, as you see here, So it says I'm really good at
shooting.
Watch this.
I need to ask you one more time.
Do you remember?
Do you?
And who are you gonna vote for?
Yeah?
Oh, you don't want me.
Oh, who said that?
Who said that?
Who said they don't remember?
Oh, night?
Bam, bam, bam!
Pop, pop, pop, pop.
All right, he's gone now.
Sorry, he left the, um, that guy, whatever his name is, it
was night, right?
He has, he has, uh, left the, the, the committee to vote, so
goodbye.
It's so unfortunate.
We were so close to finishing the vote, too.
That's unfortunate.
But, do you remember when things were cheaper, too, back in
my, back then, in the era where, you know, back in this era,
you know, my era?
Do you remember when Ram was so cheap?
I remember something about Brood Wars.
You think you were the super chat, Johnny LeCone, thank you,
thank you.
cute awesome all right so like all the other jokies i do i
do have a couple of spaces i can show you guys too so you
know i didn't just what the what did you guys got broky bird
is what broky said like you know when she's oil farming
and then see i told you i was really good at shooting who
doesn't remember Remember!
Show yourself right now!
Who was it?
A comic ray will make this dokey glitch on Zina.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Pop, pop, pop, pop!
You will always remember.
And also...
When he- when- when you start remembering,
And then when I'm like I gotta vote You're gonna vote for me
To be done Guys just think I can be both The token Chibi And
the token pixel representative Imagine that I get to do both
That's crazy
Um so now Wait What do you mean you don't remember Huh?
But you're supposed to remember How am I supposed to make
you remember If you don't remember
here we go next i forgot mr mufloff again thank you for
super chat thank you thank you oh yes oh yes oh i realized
brokey brokey bird didn't show show show dad by the way
brokey bird also has dad feature too but she forgot but i
didn't because i remember see dad's here too we all have
dads
Brokey Bird forgot about her forgot to bring her dad She
forgot to bring her dad to the interview
Yeah We all have dads I hope
And also Wow it's so Look I'm doing this I remember the
strats too I'm always remembering It's so hot Oh my god is
it hot in here Is it
smug thank you super chat thank you thank you that maybe
represent pixel i don't know when they're going to do
another vote it took them so long to get vote to get the
vote to get like an opening it only took because they got a
fucking google document made about them about how they like
lack representation so like so like that's why they open the
open the vote for this shit.
How is that?
How am I supposed to know?
What if I have to wait 50 years for the next opening?
There's not enough of us.
There's not enough pixel donkeys out there to get
representation.
Oh yeah.
Chris.
I also put on my aviators too.
And also I can go up.
Oh, up.
Down.
Yeah, we pixadokies are a rare breed.
That's why we need you guys to remember If you stop
remembering we disappear So you have to remember You have to
remember Please
Remember us
Please remember
Please remember us
But yes But yes Like I said Hello Oh I forgot to read my
about me I am an experienced social media manager Looking
for a full time position In the field of social media and
communication Also I'm 24 bit retro Is that cool?
That's so cool But yeah So, dragons.
Do I have your vote?
Do I?
What do I do?
I do a little dance on table again.
Watch this.
Look, I'm dancing on the table.
Don't you remember the quirky times, you know?
Do you remember Banjo-Kazooie?
Do you remember Crash Bandicoot?
Do you remember...
Okay, that's 3D, but like, you understand.
It's sort of the same.
era.
Do you remember Bomberman back then?
Do you remember?
Do you remember the first 151 Pokemans?
Yeah.
You like my little dance?
The GBA lasted three years and some of the panel are younger
than the GBC you will be in touch.
Patrick, I say thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You do not have my vote.
Boom.
Why?
Don't you want to remember?
Boom.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The good old times.
All right.
Any questions?
Any questions for me?
Do you guys have any questions for me?
Why am I so cute?
So it'll help you remember.
Yes.
A vote for me means more retro streams.
Think about that.
Don't you want to remember the times when she used to stream
more retro games?
And by she, I mean me.
So a vote for me.
It's a vote to remember.
I don't even know if I'm...
Am I 24-bit or 16-bit?
I couldn't count.
Like all dokees in every dokeverse.
We're not very good at counting.
I just assume 24 because that's a big number.
But do you remember all the bitties?
Am I 24-bit or am I...
Oh, I'm 24, right?
yeah I'm at least 24 there's so many colors on me I'm 24
bitty I look like I come from like Shovel Knight or some
shit I would like to have an investigation whether or not
this Doki classifies as a chibi amongst other pixel
creatures self views thank you for the super chat thank you
All right.
That's all the questions you have for me.
Any other questions?
No other questions?
All right.
But don't forget.
Don't forget.
Always remember.
A vote for me is a vote to remember.
All right.
I guess I'll call in the intern now.
I guess the interview is over.
Yeah, we're trying to find the intern again.
Yeah, I don't know.
I don't know where she went.
No.
I mean, you can call her, I guess.
I don't have her phone number.
I mean, like, she's an intern.
Like, who the fuck has an intern's phone number?
Oh, hey, guys.
Hey, guys.
I'm back.
I am back.
Oh, that was a lot longer than I expected.
Whoa, I hope you guys had a fun time remembering.
Did you guys had a fun time remembering with candidate
number three?
What do you call her?
I feel like I need to remember something, but I don't...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So what do you guys...
Oh, I forgot to ask you guys.
What are the names?
You guys figured out what names you're calling candidate
number one, two, and three.
Doki bit.
Doki bite.
I wouldn't touch this Doki bro.
Any number of infinity feet long poles.
I want to forget a happy thing.
It was a super chat thinking thing.
Yep.
I see a lot of Doki bit.
Doki brat.
Brokey bit.
Brokey.
Brokey and dokey bit.
I don't know.
Those are the finalized names.
But I trust in you guys to settle on something soon.
All right.
We are going to have our fourth and final candidate for you
guys.
And then we'll have our vote.
So.
Are you guys excited?
There is one last candidate to be the representative of all
the chibi jokies out there.
Yes.
She's at the fourth place, too, which obviously does not.
It's not really not that very lucky, but very cute.
I'm sure she will pull well.
Airboy Ninja, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All of them seems to be able to poll very well here.
Anyway, before you guys are excited, right?
All right, also.
Also, who wants to vote for Doki Bit?
Who wants to vote for her?
Did she get, got your vote?
I forgot to ask you guys that.
Who wants to vote for her?
Yeah?
Cute, but no?
Why, alright, why, why didn't she win your vote, Dragoons?
What about her?
Made it so that it was that you wanted to vote for the
others instead.
What, what, what was it about her?
Entered, please help the candidate brought a gun and shot a
fellow dragon.
I didn't, I don't, I don't, I don't, come on, guys.
They're so tiny.
What do you mean?
They can't hurt a fly.
Thank you for the super chat news.
Thank you, thank you.
I think Brokey is just more fun.
fun she made me feel old oh was she trying to make you
remember i heard of that about her yeah she she tries to
play the nostalgic angle but for some it doesn't really work
that well i don't trust nostalgia baiting
pat you're interested thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you for She was very cute, but I would prefer to
counsel a woman to bring something to the table other than
mentioning 2003.
And she's like, someone thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Are you guys ready for the last candidate, guys?
Are you guys ready?
Yeah?
Well, too bad.
You used the bathroom, so be right back.
All right.
Internus, sorry, I did not, I drank, I drank a lot of Clip
Doki, so I did not use the bathroom till now.
Uh, Rice, uh, Sharon, uh, Mehdi, Krim, McClufflicans, AK,
Nexi, oh my gosh, I'm getting closer.
Ha, well, every super chat I read, I get closer.
Solid, fight, Alan, Papa, thank you for this super chat,
thank you, thank you.
Yoko, thank you for this.
Om, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
I'm so hungry.
Om, yum, yum, yum, yum.
I like more of the neck of the second one oh yeah I see I
see yeah yeah not a lot a lot of dokeys are unfortunately
not all dokeys are you know um the you know the true
bloodline you know the true dokey bloodline you know where
uh only the purest of dokeys can do this and unfortunately
some
Doki's just aren't born with that, unfortunately.
And it's very sad, but we don't discriminate here.
We don't discriminate here.
Like, we treat all Doki's equally.
For some reason, they always demand these, like, bigger
seats for them.
But, you know, if we have to make bigger seats for these
Doki's, that means we might need to make smaller seats for
the bigger Doki's.
And, like we said, we treat every Doki equally.
So, you know, we can't be providing people different seats.
because that's not equal.
Anyway, let us bring the final jokie.
Let's call her out.
The final one.
You might even recognize her for some of you guys.
Oh.
Oh, I can't believe I'm last.
oh my gosh I don't know how I'm going to compare this to the
last Toki Chibi for this interview I I'm I'm Toki Bird um
you know it's okay I can I'm not going to complain um yeah
it's very unfortunate um you guys might some of you guys
might have seen me around already you know they promised me
they're like oh oh doki you're gonna get that seat you're
gonna get it you're gonna be a chibi prime and then i waited
i waited i waited for a year and then i find out i find out
they opened applications when they promised me i was gonna
be i was gonna get the position and they were like yeah but
we gotta be fair to all the other yokey cheebies that that
popped up you know i was like that's not fair they already
saw me some of them saw me already you said i was gonna get
the position like yeah but all these all of them they they
wanted you know they were there they wanted a chance and
they wanted to be fair to everyone and i was just like but
you said i'll get the but you said i don't understand I
waited a year!
I don't understand!
Like, they gotta be fair, you know?
There's new dokees joining every day to the DBA.
But I was like, I was first, though!
I was, I was the first one!
And then they put me last on the interview?
I don't know, I'm not shiny and new!
They all saw, you guys all saw!
Smoky, thank you for the magenta soup, thank you, thank you,
thank you for joining me.
But yeah, I guess I can, here you go, blah, blah.
Like, and then, and then the other doggies, oh my god, they
can, I understand, they can move so much.
I've been waiting for so long, and then all these new.
newfangled donkeys just pop up with all their movement and
everything?
Abuse, emotion, fallacy, thank you for the super chat, Jess.
Thank you, thank you.
And like, like, well, I mean, I could do this.
Yeah, but can those donkeys do this?
meh meh meh meh that's my special skill i'm saving that for
an entire year
it's like and then they put me last to the interview like
what the fuck was that i know
year they said they were they're like oh um we just don't
have the budget right now to include another council member
so like just wait a little longer and i'm like i've been
waiting for a year now and then they didn't even tell me
they were going to do applications i have to find out on the
news that they were opening applications on that is that
fucked up guys it's so fucked up like i even already did
streams what do you mean you I did streams because I was
like, oh, yeah, I'm the Doki Chibi.
Yeah, it's me.
And then they were like, oh, no, no, no, nope, not yet, not
yet.
Oh, just wait in here.
Here, here, you can go into the private stream room.
Yes, the private one, where all the members are.
Yes, they can see you.
And I'm like, what about the other dragons?
Like, no, no, not yet, not yet.
And then I was gone for, and then I was locked in there for
a year.
I was locked on there for a year.
Next seat for you.
If I do it next seat, will you vote for me?
Will you vote for me if I do it?
Brokekeeper stands hold strong.
Boom, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I vote for him to be not prime donkey.
Thank you for the super chat.
Astro, thank you, thank you.
you.
I was literally the OG.
But yeah.
Oh, yeah, my resume.
Okay.
Let me grab my resume real quick.
I've had this resume for an entire year now.
So, I mean, I didn't really have to update much, but here's
my resume.
I hope you well, I mean, like, you guys sort of, some of you
guys might already know what I do.
You know, like, it's just not fair.
It's just not fair but
all right let me you did you get it did you did you get my
resume i mean i to be fair i made this one i thought i had
no competition so it's like i know it's it's a little it's a
little empty but to be fair like i thought i i i didn't
think i had competition you know i mean i was the first one
to appear in the Dokiverse, so um, I know I'm a little
bearish right now, but I thought I thought I didn't have to
apply!
I just did it out of courtesy!
But, um, so, hello, um, I'm DokiBraid.
Um, my Dokiverse is C13.
Um, um, so yeah, like, about me, I'm happy to be here And
I've also been applying to be part of the DBA for One year
until I I was finally accepted And yeah, I was accepted Like
Like, you know On Christmas Day I was accepted on Christmas
Day So that was cool You know, that was pretty cool I've
been applying for a year now and I found out all the other
other dokees the other dokees they sort of got the results a
lot fast and it's like it's I don't know it feels like they
like forgot about me or something because like I think why
did it take them a year like like I was there a year ago and
it feels like you know the other dokees they were like I
didn't even wait that long you know and that's it's like
like what the fuck man like what the fuck
Peter thank you for the super chat thank you thank you you
come on down to the dokey bird 900k celebration we got og
dokey bird dokey ride dokey bite and even tune dokey tune
down not required thank you super chat thank you thank you
anyway so my my skills i have two dads yes i am one of the
uh i think the only the only dokey chibi to have two
They have two dads?
I don't think so.
Watch this.
Bam!
There's dad one.
And then.
Bam!
I have two of them.
It's hell.
Don't get two.
Do not get two.
It was a mistake.
Do not get...
But I love them very much.
I love them.
You never get to sleep.
But I love them.
They eat so much food.
Oh my god.
How do two dogs?
How do two of them eat so much?
But yes, look, two.
A vote, I didn't prep this.
I didn't think I needed votes.
A vote for me is a vote for two dads.
Just think about it.
Wow!
Wow, you- why did mom let you have two dads?
Just- just- just think about it.
Just- just think about it.
Oh yes!
And also, what else was on my- I could do this.
That!
Oh yes.
My other- my other quality is here.
It can be mine, as always.
I can- whoa!
whoa you're gonna vote for me really you're gonna you're
gonna vote for me see dad approves dad approves and then you
don't understand an entire year i i don't understand i i
could have made my first public appearance like last year
like it's even more than a year and then also
and oh yeah also you know i got my controller out too and
we're controller gaming i'm currently the only dokey in the
dokeyverse that can play on controller i don't know if
that's a nerf or a buff i
have yet to like i have yet to figure out if this is a nerf
or a buff but i can play on controller i have the aim assist
gas look i I got the aim assist, everyone.
And, like all the other dokees, put your hands up.
That's right.
Okay.
But it's okay.
It's just a joke, guys.
It's just a toy gun, so you can't fire.
Look, see?
Bam, bam.
Click, click.
It doesn't fire.
Oh, got you there, didn't I?
like you have PTSD or something that happened like maybe
like 20 or 30 minutes ago or some shit why are you so scared
guys it's just a toy see it doesn't work it's just a toy
awesome
did i get your vote though did i did i get your vote
Oh, I'm thinking of a super chat Thank you, thank you Wait,
this dokey is left-handed Yeah, I'm also left-handed here
Maybe that's why the other dokeys hated me Because I was
left-handed
Space Thank you, the super chat Thank you, thank you yours
just don't shoot so um what do you guys think you guys have
any questions about me i mean some of you guys already asked
me questions like a year ago but you know um do you do you
guys have any questions for me yes i will be here to
represent the left-handed gamers too you know
If I have a nickel for every time I've been flurring by a
tomato during the election.
Oh my god, Jack, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What questions do you guys have for me?
Guys, remember, a vote for me is a vote for two dads.
Oh, the vote, the polls will be out after my interview.
It's going to be on straw poll because we can make the
results anonymous.
Not hidden.
So it'll be a surprise for everyone, including us.
We're going to be doing a straw poll.
Do you guys remember straw poll?
Sorry.
I know, like, I'm not trying to be like dokey bit, guys.
But do you guys remember straw poll?
Cat, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, we got to ensure the integrity of the election So we
got to keep the results anonymous, you know
You seem nice How do you feel about bedrock and its
potential uses?
Thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank you Blazing,
thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank you Two dads,
you got my vote Exactly Two dads, double the dads Double the
fun Double the bills Double the food Not double the sleep,
apparently.
No, they're just exactly alike.
They're literally just the same.
But there's two of them now.
Double the lack of sleep, exactly.
Well, here we guys.
Don't have any more questions.
I guess.
I guess it's time to go then.
all right it was nice seeing you guys again i'm glad some of
you guys didn't forget about me that really that helps a lot
i was like oh my god all the other all the other dokees are
like new and shiny but they've already seen me a year ago i
was like when can i have my turn and then And I'm glad, too.
But I really appreciate you guys remembering me and, like,
you know, not forgetting about me and everything.
So I hope I got your vote, guys.
I really hope I do.
And I hope I'm not locked back in for another year.
I hope so.
Anyway, I guess I'll go now.
It was nice seeing you guys again.
there's one more dokey
there's one more
I oh my gosh I didn't prepare for anything I sorry I they
they didn't let me apply I I know I I try I I was like let
me apply and they're like you're not you're you're 3d and
I'm Like, but I'm, I'm still Cheeby.
I'm Cheeby.
But, apparently.
Apparently.
Um, they're not, they're not looking for representatives for
3D Cheeby's yet.
Because, um, we didn't have our, we didn't have our 3D debut
yet.
So, I broke in.
i didn't even make a resume my mouth don't work so good too
um but but but i i'm very passionate and oh my gosh okay i
gotta go sorry i'm on i don't think they're sending the
guards goodbye
okay well that was awkward okay it's just sorry there's just
four candidates there's no five sorry sorry guys um if you
saw at Doki anywhere, please contact your local Doki
authorities or tell your local Doki right now.
Um, she was not supposed to appear today.
Or like, she was, oh man, she, that, that's so, guys, I'm
sorry.
Like, that won't happen again.
Like I said, um, 3D Chibis are not included in um, in the
voting process.
Uh, It is in a different category.
Like I said, you know, we do, we already have a Cheeby Doki.
We already have a Cheeby Doki.
And we already have a 3D Cheeby Doki.
So it's like, you know, yeah, I know like, you know, the
council doesn't have, doesn't have the, I have a 3D
representative, but there's not enough Doki's to, we didn't
even have our debut sir you know if we have to give a 3d
chibi a a representative then we have to give the regular 3d
doki a representative but she didn't even have she hasn't
even had a 3d debut yet guys you know you understand right
you you understand anyway don't worry this won't happen
again um she has been taken back to her doki verse uh where
uh you know maybe her Doki port is, you know, suspended for
a little bit.
And, well, maybe we'll see her again one day.
Maybe, maybe, you know?
I mean, we saw Canada number four again, guys.
We saw her again after a year.
So, you know, maybe we'll see her again, too, in a year or
two, guys.
Maybe that'll happen.
Anyway, what did you think?
about Tokyo Chibi number four.
The last candidate.
The last one.
There was only four candidates, guys.
Only four.
Free 3D Chibi Tokyo.
Thank you.
Airport Ninja.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
Mary Pample, I'm pretty sure she won't pull well.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
Yeah?
You liked her?
You like her?
How about the people who didn't vote for her?
What was about her that made you guys, you know...
It's like a focus group, you know?
Like, what did you get?
Why didn't you want to vote for her, you know?
It's a good focus group for us to prepare for the next one.
Too sad.
I mean, me locked up in a year would do that to Adoki, you
know?
Don't get him, that's my heart.
She got my vote.
You'll be thinking of the super chat thing.
Thank you.
So, while the other Doki, like I said, this building is like
run by three Doki right now.
The other Doki's have yet to wake up from the nap gadget.
We're still running these things here.
What were the names that you've assigned them as a group?
There's Brokey.
Brokey.
Dokey bit.
Do you guys want dokey bit or dokey bite?
Which one's your favorite?
You know, I'll put a poll on YouTube.
This would be the one poll on YouTube.
Dokey bit or dokey bite.
I'm gonna make the poll, guys.
And then what is the fourth one?
What is the fourth one's name?
GB Prime Come on guys, come on Don't enable her We give her
the prime name We have to give everyone the prime name Guys,
come on
Look, we all treat every doki equally guys Come on
Alright Are you still making that pull?
Okay, they're still making that pull Alright guys, don't
worry Alright Okay, we're going to go, we're doing this by
order of their appearance.
Doki Brent.
Doki.
Brokey.
Uh.
Doki bit.
And then the fourth one.
Chee B prime.
Fine.
You guys get Chee B prime, I guess.
I don't get paid at all for this so like I'm not gonna fight
it fight it
Let's see
All right
I'm gonna make sure that this works real quick
Are you guys all right guys
Vote for your jokie chibi Representative.
Lobbying for Brokey Burger.
ORA is too powerful.
Dora, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, are you guys, are we lobbying now?
All right, let's see.
Who's gonna win with the lobbying?
Let's just pull work, guys.
Sorry, we're interns right now.
So like, we don't really know how to.
We're learning as we go.
I have to vote for Brokey Bird and hope for Cat years down
the line Sister Doakini wants to chop off my ankles Thank
you for the super chat Thank you Hey look I said no Don't
take bribes from the dokees I didn't say don't take bribes
from the dragoons guys That's different Vote for the poll
Okay let me do a text real quick A text
voting link in chat there we go remember remember to vote
everyone every vote counts this is the most important
election of your life right now who knows when we'll open
the board the council to more donkeys and the future.
Brokey bird supremacy.
Boom.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Who knows?
We might not have another day like this ever again.
See who's winning.
I can see who's winning.
Oh, wait.
The votes are really close.
I won't say who.
I won't say...
I won't say who, but...
Remember to vote, everyone.
This will be a cheapy representative of all dokees out there
in the dokeyverse.
Your vote matters.
A vote for Brad is a vote for Skater.
Wait, I voted the wrong one, though.
Doki Viz.
A vote for a chance at finishing Starcraft.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
No, you cannot have a day.
Today is the only day to vote, guys.
Vote or die.
An actual Dima Dima.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
A vote for Doki is a promise.
A vote for justice.
You've got the touch.
You've got the power.
Oh my god.
It is so close.
The law is actually working too like there we have some
undecided voters right now oh my god oh my god wait there's
a third contender there's a third contender just popped up
to change the tide me we have undecided sign the bonus right
now who's winning
oh my god it's actually so close I oh my god it's so fucking
close right now oh this is so exciting for me the winner is
E33 it's E33 came in out of nowhere that's our third
contender you guys gotta get the lobbyists you have to
figure out a way to sway the undecided voters you have to
figure a way to win the undecided voters
the e33 did it again congratulations to clear obscure we're
becoming the new chief representative of the dba
Thank you, thank you.
Gio, thank you, the super chat.
I will say the, I will let you guys know the votes are
really, really, really close.
Like, I'm as surprised.
I'm very surprised how close these votes are.
This is a reason why I also didn't want to show the results
to you guys, like, while I'm voting, because that influenced
the choice as well.
So, like, you know, you'd be like, oh, they're winning
anyway, so I'll vote for it.
Or, like, oh, they're winning anyway, so I won't vote for
it.
But here, you guys don't know who's winning right now.
So you're voting with your hearts.
You're voting with your hearts right now.
But I will say it's very close.
So each vote actually matters a lot.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Five member gifts and jockey.
Ratt wins.
Lucky.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Broke, she is just cool like that, bro.
All right.
I'll set it.
I'll do a timer.
Voting closes at 7.48.
You have three more.
Is that cheapy jockey with a steel chair?
You're going to think of the super chat.
Thank you.
In three minutes, I shall be closing the polls.
That's right.
Your vote matters.
Release Cheapy Prime from the coal mine.
So help me, Gordon.
Thank you, the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Doki Prap is the only correct choice.
Dragons.
Bird, they give the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Vote for a real, bro.
vote for Brokey.
Oh my god.
That's crazy.
I feel bad for the fourth Dokey.
Don't worry.
We won't tell her.
We won't tell her that she got the least amount of votes.
Mel, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You wanted to vote for Dokey, Ben.
You want to vote for Dokey, Ben.
You want to remember.
No, I don't.
Do I only regret what this entire process is that you didn't
let us see the vote, so we can't pivot the vote out of
wrong.
That is why I didn't let you guys see the vote.
So you vote with your heart, even so you don't know who's
losing, and you vote with your heart.
I want you to vote with your heart on who you think deserves
it the most.
A vote for Doki Brat is a vote for Doki.
How dare you not let it be rigged?
Exactly!
You can't rig this!
You can't fucking work together to take someone down.
This is our last step to all our one!
Doki is Prime Believers!
Adjo, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Alright.
It looks like...
the results are in
let us
let me try and figure out how to close it
close settings I already stopped the count guys so it
doesn't matter if you vote anymore I already stopped the
count oh it closed poll and the poll has been closed
stop the count the votes are here who won it was very very
close in the beginning it was like all three of them there
were three like 10 to 15 votes apart from each other one of
them two of them were like five votes apart from each other
and they were always like going up and down between each
other they were fighting for second and third place but the
first place and second place were always like 10 to 15 votes
apart from each other it was very very close it was very fun
to watch live and only me watching it
So, it's up to me to announce the winners.
But we can't announce it here, guys.
We gotta go somewhere nicer to announce it, guys.
So, why don't we head off right now?
Come on, guys.
I'll take you guys to our amphitheater, guys.
Funded by your fellow dragoons.
Wow!
I can't believe.
I can't believe the boats are in.
You're new.
New what, Doki?
Cheapy representative.
Of all the Doki Cheebies in the Dokiverse is...
Drum roll, please?
Come on, dragons.
Yeah, give me some drum rolls.
If you want to know who won.
Where's the drum rolls, guys?
Five, four, three, two, one!
TV Prime?
Oh my god.
Thank you to everyone who voted for me.
I didn't think I'd win.
I thought you'd all forgot about me.
Thank you everyone for voting.
The results were very, very close.
actually crazy look how close the the poll was oh my god
released the files i literally just released it i thank you
a vote for me is a vote for two dads guys don't give it so
Thank you, everyone.
Thank you, my food has been nothing.
Let's go.
Thank you, everyone.
We have two dads now.
But yes, as the intern was saying, because we were looking
at the polls as well live with the other jokies, because,
you know, we're allowed to look at the polls.
And, um, um, so, oh my god, dad's here too.
Oh my god, the couple of the barks.
Um, as you guys know, um, okay, up.
Three of them were really close.
It was literally like five to 15 votes apart between the top
three.
They were always fighting for a first, second, and third
place.
but I I got past it I maintained first place for the longest
and I kept first place too so thank you everyone for voting
I really appreciate it I thought you all forgot about me and
we're gonna vote for the new shiny thing but thank you I
really appreciate all the votes die I promise all of you
guys that I will for the dragons and the donkeys.
I will promise to get what you as always wanted.
Because you voted for me.
And I will be there for the people.
Matt, you guys did.
Thank you in the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Also, my two dads.
My Nina go pee.
Give me a sec.
I gotta go check on him.
I'm back.
Sorry.
Both dads before I streamed.
So before we started the voting process and the interviews
and everything.
So I was like, what do you want?
And he was just like, he just looked at me.
It was like food.
Oh, both of them looked at me was like food.
And I was like, I fed you before the stream.
And he's like, yeah, but I could have more food.
I mean, isn't this, it's like a victory, you know, a victory
laugh.
He's like, where's the victory meal, you know?
Where's the victory celebration meal?
And I'm like, after, after, after.
Airloom chibi turkey bird prime Thank you for the Akasupa
Airborne Ninja Thank you, thank you I knew you guys always
believed in me I thought I was gonna get the spot Guys, I
really didn't think I'll get the spot Because, you know, it
was like You know, like They said I was gonna be the OG And
then they're like oh just wait here for a bit we'll get back
to you we'll we'll get back to you you can have your little
debut soon i was like okay when will i have my debut and
like soon soon just just wait a little longer and i waited
and i waited and then they brought in three other candidates
and i was like what do you mean three other candidates i
thought i was the only one but thank you all for the vote we
got our justice today guys we got our justice today oh yeah
apparently i have a press conference now.
I'll see you guys.
I'll see you guys at the press conference, everyone.
I gotta make a statement on the news now.
Guys, I'm gonna be on the TVs.
Alright, I'm heading over now, guys.
I'm heading over.
Oh my gosh.
I'm on.
I'm so scared.
I'm on the TVs.
Oh my god.
Breaking news.
Hello.
Hi.
Oh, hi, yes, yes, I am the new Nuki first representative at
the, yes, oh, I'm so scared, sorry, I'm so nervous, this is
my first time on the TVs and everything, hello, hello, um,
the first, that's me, the first ever, Chibi, board member,
uh, yes, this is my first public appearance, um, questions,
questions, oh, there's so many questions, there's so many
cameras, but as the first Chibi representative of the
Dokiverse, I promise, and I want to say thank you to all the
dragons who voted for me for this position, thank you to all
of them, I promise that I will represent the And we will
finally have equal rights between dragons and donkeys.
Say it with me, dragons.
We will finally close the gap between the donkeys and the
dragons.
That is right.
Huh?
What?
Wait, what do you mean?
Oh.
oh oh i oh really oh oh oh okay oh oh oh oh yeah okay yeah
yeah no you're right you're right yeah yeah yeah no i get it
i get it i get it um yeah no no i get it yeah okay yeah no i
definitely will yeah i i'll i'll say it yeah um so uh
scratch that um so something happened And, um, due to new
developments, um, I'm gonna have to raise the Dragoon tax by
50%.
Very tough decision.
I know it really pains me to say that, uh, but, you know,
um, tough decisions have to be made, and it really, really
pains me to do this.
But don't worry, guys.
Progress will be made one day, and I will be here for it.
Yay!
Like you said, a vote for me was a vote for two dads.
Maybe even three dads?
Come on in!
Yeah!
Thank you, thank you, everyone.
Thank you.
Yeah!
thank you everyone look look at all you can go yeah yeah
yeah don't worry don't worry i got you oh oh wait oh oh oh
oh yeah that's good okay thank you thank you thank you yeah
See, I told you I'd say it.
Thank you all.
Thank you, everyone.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you all for voting.
Any questions?
For your new board member?
Don't worry, I'm here for the people.
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
I will always be here for the people.
As always, thank you all for voting for me.
Don't worry.
It's gonna be a great year.
So great.
Where are your dragon taxes going towards?
To the donkeys, of course.
Because we all want to help the donkeys.
Right, dragons?
Chio, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Dad, the two dads are happy.
Aren't you happy that they're happy, guys?
Anyway, my closing statement.
is thank you
did you guys enjoy the stream did you guys it's like live
from new york it's saturday night that's my thing it's
saturday night live and for that's like live from dokeyverse
it's not a true case celebration
thank you the super chat thank you thank you all right let
me add a bgm real quick guys that's just wants food yeah
should we give him a little treat now that i won i did until
we lost the bro today all right let me grab which one was
the bgm for this uh was it i'm trying to remember what bgm
was it Oh my gosh, I don't remember.
Give me a sec.
Try to remember what BGM did we use.
I don't know if you guys want to still listen to this.
The same BGM over here.
No, over here.
Justice for Doki Brat.
Mega, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, Dave.
What do you mean?
I was for the people.
I need to fix this line.
in the middle that's bothering me right now I'm too scared
to put a BGM in that like does not work okay give me a sec I
go technically the bit is over so let me go to I'll go here
I want to know what the okay it's called focus group BGM
okay there you go I'm back I just want to add a BGM for us
before we go straight into it focus group I have a lot of
stuff.
All right.
I fix.
I fix an image.
All right, guys.
I'm going to give Dad a little treat.
Because he powers through it all.
He really did.
But I need to fix this real quick.
Where the fuck is this gray line coming from?
Did I fix it?
Oh, it is from that.
I'm just not coming off.
come on fix itself why is there a white gray line there is
it from the chat no it's from oh it is but you're right
there we go yay we fixed it thank you guys are so smart
don't worry i'm for the people don't worry dragons all right
guys um oh brokey won't forget to say happy birthday for
duck oh i will i will upload the People, thank you for the
super chimes.
I hope you're staying at that.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear dog.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Yippee!
All right, let me...
I realized I forgot to add something.
Yeah?
Chee- Chee-B-Prime.
There you go.
I deserve to be named.
That should mean Chibi Prime.
Wait, I deserve to change my font, too.
I would like to be where is it?
Yeah.
That's me.
I'm Chibi Prime.
Yeah, thank you, the Akasufa.
Thank you.
Reimbursement for Chibi is skin cysts because something
tells me that they weren't free.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Um, it was fun.
Um, like I said, um, I've guys enjoyed the little, the, the
lore expansion of the Dokiverse.
Now you guys know why, uh, why I was all over the place.
And I was like, you know, I needed more time like doing this
fucking bit I needed yeah I was like you know I was all and
then there's more too because we have our our new years like
new year's countdown event too but thank you all for 900k
subscribers dragons I really appreciate it I hope you guys
had a really fun time watching this adventure uh there is
another event um and i announced it in the member stream
this morning um and um it's gonna be public anyway because
um we were gonna like you know people will see it in our
schedules but on new year's eve uh on december 31st we're
doing pst time zone at 10 p.m pst This me and the Sloppy
Sisters will be doing a special countdown stream For West
Coast for PST time zone and yeah, so I don't know if Snuffy
will be streaming but Lamo and Mint won't be streaming it
They just wanted to chill with me So huge thank you to the
Sloppy Sisters for joining me on this event because it is my
project uh my event and they i asked if they wanted to join
me they would like to join me and they're like yeah so i
really appreciate them joining me for the event and um you
know giving up their time to be part of it um i said they
were allowed they can stream they were allowed to stream i
gave them the like the privilege to know that i meant like
you know they wanted to stream they can if they want to um
and uh they said they're like no we'll just we just want to
chill and hang out and so I will be streaming it um uh yeah
Lyman's already gonna be in 2026 already uh because she's on
the other side of the earth uh well in the middle of the
world for me and uh it's gonna be like I said December 31st
at 10 p.m PST we will be having our sloppy sisters new
year's countdown together uh and this project has been in
the works for half a year I think like around more than a
half a year so I really look forward to a lot of people work
very hard on this project so I'm really excited to debut it
next week like I said lots of stuff going on um I didn't
even have time to write down the credits for all the skin
suits that we got today so I'll just be typing the text out
and stuff um I need to notify them that I didn't even notify
them that I was gonna debut it I only notified like half the
people that was debuting it today because like um I was
but uh i hope you guys all enjoyed it uh because like i said
i've been holding on to all the skin suits for a while now
for a special occasion and i thought uh because i didn't i
was like oh yeah like i'm not sure when i'll be debuting it
but i want to debut it at a special time and you know 900k
was the special time you know the special event for it i
figured um and i want you guys to know up with it this week
i came up with the like i had the idea to do the um to do uh
uh like to reveal everything i had the idea to reveal
everything on 900k by i for the longest time i couldn't
figure out like how do i do it how do i how do i debut this
and that's what i mean i was telling you guys ideas come to
me when I'm like so last minute and it fucking sucks I
literally finalize the script for this like I improved all
the interviews by the way the interviews was all improv but
like the beginning of it like um the beginning of it like
the the introduction to everything I wrote it like the last
15 minutes before the stream was about to start like like
you know when I was Like introducing like the internship And
everything that was, you know, obviously I was Like I had to
write the guideline and Everything else was like improv
And huge shout out to the editor To the editor cause they
edit the video within Two days like a day and a half I would
say a day and a half Huge shout out to Stardust Raven Who
has done our shorts and stuff And some of our video
explaining and iffin were doing the sound, the sound for
like, like finding the sound effects and the music.
So I literally finished the script for The Council of
Doki's.
I think like three to three days ago, three to three to four
days ago, I finished the script for the Council of Doki's
video, like the videos we had.
And I recorded all of it, like within like two hours.
And I felt like I felt like a schizo talking to myself like
I was just like I was just like okay, I'm interacting with
me me me and me and I'm just talking to all the jerkeys in
my head And so I was like writing yeah Yeah, and I was just
like thinking like I hope they think it's funny and not too
cringe I the voices in my head
Yeah, actually, actually a full skitso moment right there to
all the dookies.
So huge shout out to, um, I'll write it down too.
I'll give you guys their, uh, their thing.
I'll write it down.
Like I said, I didn't really, I didn't really like prepared,
like, the credits page because like i said i didn't have any
time left guys i really didn't to prepare i wish i did have
time to prepare credits page but unfortunately um i had to
cut corners i didn't have time to make like a like a
graphics for everyone all right editor
sound sound guy all
right I know the text is big guys I will fix it I just whoa
video intro video Council of Doki's.
I'm sorry.
It's not as professional as the other stuff I just did.
I'm so sorry.
But I hope you guys had a lot of fun.
But a lot of these people also deserve huge shout outs.
There you go.
all right i'm gonna uh wait council of dokey's dokey's video
i am going to give oh wait dad stop barking okay it's fine
never mind i'm not gonna indulge this uh gordon thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you ducky you mentioned
earlier i got a christmas gift for us yes i'll show i forgot
about giving us your christmas gift during the christmas
stream because i was so tired by that time i was i was
really tired And I forgot all about it.
I'm so sorry.
But after the credits, I will give you guys your Christmas
present.
And I hope you guys like it.
Zero, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Congrats on 900K.
Well deserved.
Also, the real Chibi win.
The dragons vote for our great leader and won in the end.
There is a dokey prime god justice.
Thank you for the super chat.
Zero, thank you, thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
everyone um i cannot wait for 2026 when i can relax a little
bit because there's not a lot of event oh my gosh oh that's
so stressful like i think like um i want you guys to know
for my anniversary in february it's not going to be as super
big or grand because i focused on my attention on 900k and
new years as well so um it's not gonna be as big and grand
as the new year's event and the 900k because like i said i
focused all on that and everything is so close to each other
everything is so close to each other so i'm just warning you
guys right now there's so many events and so little me other
doki's from the doki versus helping.
I thought as a council we'd work to get there to get there.
Alright, so let me grab the other stuff real quick, guys.
Alright, I'm just searching up all the um
all the creators of all my new skin suits
all right um I just want to make sure I credit all of them
properly so you guys want to stick by to figure out who who
was our creators
wait is she oh my god give me a sec guys oh my god she
changed her discord name like i said i'm doing this live
everyone i'm doing this live i'm sorry okay all right i got
i got i got the discord name i got i bet she changed her
disc that's how long i've been holding on to this one i've
been holding on to this one for so long that she changed she
changed her discord name
that's crazy all right so is this a new wait okay wait oh my
god oh my god wait is this wait a minute guys she like sent
me an updated version of gb prime and i didn't even notice
okay we'll fix that later I'll fix that later.
I'll fix that later.
Oh my god, I didn't even realize she updated.
Oh, it's just more fluidity.
It's just more fluidity.
For CheeB Prime.
By the way, it was just more like fluidity.
CheeB Prime.
Um.
Artist.
Melby.
And her.
Blue Sky.
she's on blue sky not uh not twitter she is on blue sky this
is how blue sky url works i don't know i'm not on blue sky i
i don't know there's too many social media so i stopped i
stopped going to show social media and then there you go
this is for chibi prime and uh
Rigger is
Oh, this one Uh
Those These are the talented people These are the talented
people that made me Make Chibi Prime Right here Velvete and
Aria Please check them out They're very talented people
Shout out to them.
They made Chibi Prime.
I can post her.
Yeah, I can post it in chat.
Here.
This is the Rigger.
And this is the artist.
Alright, now the other.
Now the other skin suits.
I gotta disappear now.
Alright.
First off.
will go with the least to the least voted and the most voted
so hello you thought you saw the last of me I will make you
remember so this was done by one person um let me grab Let
me grab it.
It is done by...
Oh my gosh, the Twitter DMs now are so weird.
I'm sorry, this is like very not fluid.
Doki bit.
Artists.
And...
Check them out That maid Don't keep it Check them out I
don't know I saw the I remember I saw like their Iron Mouse
Their Iron Mouse model And I was just like Oh my god That's
so cute Because they did it for like fun And I was like Oh
my god That's so cute And then I asked them like Oh Can I
Can I, uh, get one, two?
And then, bam!
I'm here now.
So huge shout out to them.
Alright, next up.
Next up.
Gotta disappear again.
Who is second third?
Who is... Wait, I got... I don't remember the results.
Who is third?
Oh, okay.
This is third.
I didn't look at the... It was so close, guys.
The results are so close.
Of course I'm not gonna remember It was I remember it first
and last
Okay Oh yeah Me It's me and also here's I forgot to show dad
on this one But this one I think a lot of people sort of
like Recognize this one Because it's a very popular Cheeby
model So a lot of A lot of A lot of streamers, a lot of
YouTubers have a similar one in the style and like, you
know, I remember like being on the waitlist for this for a
very long time.
Because like, you know, obviously it's really cute, you
know.
Yeah.
So, Roki.
Yeah, I mean, I have, I think my favorite is, I think my
favorite is the Sleepwear one.
That is my favorite.
I think it's just a little...
the little slippers yeah I think my slip those slippers is
my favorite for sure um but all let me grab let me grab
their thingy no no no no no no no no so the creator artist
and artist and rigor there's Go Rhea!
Bro, cute.
Yeah.
Oh.
Please check them out.
Very talented, too.
All of them are very, very talented.
I actually had more.
I had more.
I wanted to commission more.
And I forgot to.
I was like on a wait list for like two more, but then like,
and then when they were like, oh, you're up, I forgot about
it.
And I was like, oh, I'm so sorry, I was so busy, I didn't
see your DM.
I was just like, I'm so, I'm so sorry.
This is why I pay in advance.
Usually like, if I can, I would be like, can I please pay in
advance and like, and I'll give you all the details and
everything.
And then you just do it because like sometimes I just miss
DMs because I am, I am, there's so much work, guys.
There is so much work.
Oh, my God.
So, like, there were two others that, like, they told me,
like, oh, I finally made it to yours.
Like, you, like, oh, and then, like, and then they're like,
can you give me the details?
Because I was like, can I give you the details?
Like, now?
And you're like, no, please wait till you're on your wait
list.
I'm like, okay.
And then I, and then I was just, I was in the fucking
trenches.
I was, I was in the fucking trenches.
Sorry.
So we did end up.
We didn't get it.
We could have got two more cannons.
But then I think that would be too long.
We would be like, and another one.
What was it?
What's the phrase called?
That's not all.
Is that what, like, I forgot.
There was a famous phrase.
Like, not another one, but like, uh, but wait.
Oh yeah.
But wait.
There's one more.
Yeah.
But wait.
There's more.
Yeah.
Yeah, thank God we only had four.
But wait, there's more.
It could have been.
All right, and finally, second place.
I gotta disappear again.
Whoa.
I got second place.
I saw some people were asking, like, when will the skater
outfit be done?
It will be done in one to two weeks.
It could be done in time, but that's okay.
We will have Skater Boy Doki soon.
It'll be done in one to two weeks, guys.
But here are the talent people that worked on Skater.
Oh, not Skater Boy.
Doki Brat.
Yeah, like, definitely has picked that name.
Really?
I can't believe it.
let me grab their Twitter handle.
Oh, I don't know the Twitter linked.
Okay, I gotta figure this out then.
Your Twitter's not linked.
Give me a sec.
I gotta figure this out.
You don't have a link to their Discord.
But I don't know.
Grabbing it.
all right got the artist and then let me grab the okay
artist is this one i remember i saw there like i said i saw
like you know the the skin suits and i was like oh my god
it's so cute and i was like it's so fluid and i was like i
want one too And then I'll just be like, hey, hey, buddy,
are you open for commissions?
And then...
They don't have their...
Wait, they also don't have their thing linked.
What is their Twitter handle?
Okay, give me a sec.
They also don't have it linked.
I need to figure out what their Twitter handle is.
That is the most unfortunate thing.
All right, I have to do investigation.
I do a communication all on Discord because I cannot handle
Twitter DMs.
I am so bad with Twitter DMs.
I hope you guys are going crazy with that song on loop.
This song has been on loop for the last three hours.
But no, I think Twitter DMs are just so messy in general.
The fact that, like, I, uh, I wish you can cat, like, you
can't, like, you can't categorize DMs, too.
Like, in overall, like, Discord and Twitter.
Give me a sec.
I'm still trying to find, I'm trying to find their Twitter
account, so I can just link it to you guys.
Oh, there you go.
I found it.
Okay.
all right here you go um so for this one i even linked to
like the the the skin suit i saw and i was like oh i want
one like that because it was so cute so i saw this and
that's why i was like i want that it's so cute i saw it this
and i was like well i don't think it was like this exact
video but it's like very similar and I just thought it was
super super cute and I was like I want one too I want one
just like that and then the rest was history and then this
got second place yeah all everyone is so talented but I'll
post there and then here is
there's the rigor and the artist
But yes, those are Everyone Oh yeah I did say For those who
Actually voted for me I think this is my favorite
I think I love this face the most This is so good
And this face is my favorite face.
Everyone did a really great job.
Nah.
I fucking love that.
And also, Dad.
Dad's here, too.
Nah.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for the love of God.
Use the Taka's word.
I'm using them a lot more than I used to now, guys.
I'm improving.
I'm actually improving little by little.
Mm-hmm.
I'm getting better at it.
I think I realized I could use my...
I'm actually using my stream deck now, too.
Slowly.
Back in the old times, I rarely ever use any toggles.
So, like...
So this is an improvement now, guys.
This is an improvement.
But yeah, I think that's everything.
Am I missing anything, guys?
Am I missing anything?
Just want to be sure.
How many times would you use if you had a hundred percent
key for it?
Thank you, Lucerne Chat.
Next thing, thank you.
Oh, the Christmas gift.
Yes, yes, yes.
So some of you guys might have already seen it.
So you guys may have already seen it because I said they
could post it.
But I'll show it, guys, for those who didn't see it.
Oh, wait.
It's not this.
Because they already posted it.
And this is the thing I forgot to show.
Let me see if I can find it.
Wait, where is it?
Oh, there it is.
So.
Yeah!
Um.
I got a bunch of wallpaper.
I got two wallpapers.
animated for um so if you have uh wall seam wallpaper engine
um you can have animated wallpapers now um i might uh uh so
you guys can download this on steam let me grab the link i
have the link here i like linked it to myself be like
remember to post it and then i forgot to post it so yes if
you have uh steam wallpaper what's it called wallpaper
engine i think that's what it's called right so i got these
animated as a christmas gift
yeah so yeah yeah it's called wallpaper engine on steam and
you can have animated wallpapers and there's a steam cell is
there still there's still steam cell going on too so um it's
like I think it's like five dollars Canadian dollars yeah or
five I think it's five Canadian dollars and I also got the
oh this one's bigger I also got the summer outfit done too
so the summer outfit is this one for those who want to
download it and I will be making more wallpapers I will be
uploading more wallpaper animated because I know like the
there's like some for in the bounty hunter debut and I will
be getting those updated uploaded at another time I just
gotta find all the files but yes that was my Christmas gift
I hope you guys will enjoy using it and like the animated
Like, the animated wallpapers as well for Christmas.
Yeah.
I'm going to enjoy the Christmas gift.
Music, thank you for the- welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Alright, I just want to say, guys, thank you all for 900K
dragoons.
That is a lot of dragoons.
Thank you, everybody.
I'm feeling mushy right now.
I'm feeling mushy.
Alright, dad, get it down.
I don't even know what Yuki Chibi to use to be mushy right
now.
Well, we should use Chibi Prime because, you know, she is
the winner.
So, I'll be mushy with her.
I feel so relaxed now that it's over.
now that like the the the bit is over i don't have to like
worry about like what do i say next you know i'm gonna be
like what do i have to say next i mean i gotta be like
follow follow it the god i'll put i put that on my head i
have the stress is gone now well not really i still have i
still next week I still have next week not really I'm still
stressed out a mushy tomato quick we have to eat it before
it goes bad next day thank you the super chat thank you
thank you oh but yeah I will say shout out to all the
dragons new and old and those yet to come thank you you for
being here for my journey like this is a huge milestone a
huge goal hit that like button if you want to subscribe
smash that subscribe button but sorry sorry i got i got
distracted there um anyway uh but it is a huge milestone and
uh thank you everyone for being here for me and i hope i can
be there for you guys for as long as you guys want me to you
know uh kaz thank you super chat thank you thank you hey
toky you're doing very cash money keep it up son thank you
thank you uh father
thank you everyone um i i really appreciate everyone for
being here um
streams and my silly ideas um it was really nice it was
really fun being super creative again i feel like i haven't
done these super creative streams in a while you know um so
i had a lot of fun uh Me able to do that again and just go
wild with my dumb shit in my head.
Bro, thank you for the Akasuka.
Thank you.
Thank you for everything, boss.
Love you.
Thank you, friend.
Thanks for the raccoon pictures.
Thank you.
Okay, so Twitter did this new update where you have to open
the DMs to hide the Twitter notifications now.
Because in the past, you can just click on the DM button,
and then the notification goes away.
So, because Frail sends me a raccoon picture every day, I
have to open her DMs now to get rid of the notification.
I can't, like, just click on the icon, and then, like, I
don't have to, in the past, you don't have to click on the
DM itself.
it actually stays there now so like and then like when it
says like two or three messages it'll be from the same
person and then like um isn't that harassment so so like so
like i actually have to open her dms to like get rid of it
because she was the target audience for this update yeah so
now i actually have to look at it
um but yes oh also the really fun thing i um about this is
that you know how like i always say um branding is
everything so obviously i i don't want like you know uh for
my actual like for the the the big skin suits um um you know
i want to keep with my mama for as long as i can just
because of like you know branding and i always loved her all
right um but like with the i can experiment with all kinds
of styles you know all kinds of cheebies and all different
kinds of styles and that's something i wanted to do when i
first started streaming i was like for those who were a bark
knight uh who was a uh bark knight um um i this is like lore
from a long time ago but I talked about how before Iron
Mouse did her thing where she got skin suits from so many
different artists and stuff um I talked about doing wanting
to do that before Iron Mouse did that and I remember talking
to my bark knights I was like I want to be able to have all
these different skin suits from all these different artists
and I'll see their interpretation of dokeybird and and i was
before i uh graduated the first time um i was actually gonna
debut a new skin suit you can actually see it in the vod too
you can see in the um in the graduation vod where i was like
showing everyone like this was gonna be my next skin suit
that i was gonna like do and i was gonna increase i was
gonna like have more and more like get more and stuff and
like increase my collection of different artists and stuff
like that.
And this was like something I actually really wanted to do.
And I think like, I think I would have been the first one
person to like sort of do that.
Because I was like, I was going to do that.
And then, and then I had like one plan and it already and
everything.
I was going to fucking do it.
But now I'm obviously like, I don't really want to do it.
Like I can't really do that anymore.
But I could do that for Cheebies.
And I love collecting different artists, like
interpretations of me as well, as well as collecting like
different outfits and everything.
Because, you know, I love, I just love seeing how other
artists draw me and stuff.
And just how I love art in general.
I was a big, a lot of, I commissioned a lot of artists back
then.
Like I wasn't even like, I wasn't anyone.
Everyone sort of knew me as the person that they would see
my, I was an OC.
first like i was like you see like me and they're like oh
it's this person this person commissioned so many artists
because like i just love art in general and i just love
seeing people draw me in general like draw my oc in general
so i was like my like me i was everywhere like retro doki
was everywhere because of it um um so like that was just
another thing like vtune was another thing to be to collect
you know like if i was thank god i'm not in like i'm not a
into like art galleries and stuff because I think I would
have gone broke with how spending millions of dollars on art
like spending like you know like framed gallery photos and
like not for gallery art and stuff like that um and uh and
you know being able to have like all these different chibi
uh skin suits is really fun I hope to expand my collection
more and more in the future
Thank you.
Not to get almost sure anything, but I'm proud of where you
are now compared two years ago.
Your story helped me so much when I also had a bad time
right now as well.
Thank you, and congrats.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
I hope you're feeling a lot better now.
Thank you so much, and we can do this journey together.
Snads, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, y'all, for all the laughs and fun times over the
years.
Here's to many more with old friends and new faces.
It's prime time for Chibi Doki.
chat thank you thank you um oh yeah dad is like i don't want
treats i think he just wants treats because like i fed and
walked him before the stream um just because like i wasn't
sure like how long it was gonna be but yes um i'm gonna open
the door check i opened the door for him and he's just gonna
come in and look at me and go out I'm
back.
He's in my lap now.
Ah, fuck.
Okay.
He like, I was like trying to talk and he stuck his...
He tried to stick his nose.
You know, like, I don't understand dogs.
They like, you know, like, they see your mouth open.
They're like, I'm going to stick my tire, my tire snout in
that hole.
Like, I'm like, what the fuck is wrong?
Hole is gold.
snap uh oh yeah but thank you again for the super chat thank
you thank you yeah that's how they say hello yeah
all right let me up there you go two dads um but yeah thank
you you guys made despite all the ups and downs um from 2025
um whenever i feel sad whenever i feel lonely um cheer me up
and honestly like you know i always keep going because i
always want to make you guys happy like how you guys make me
happy too so thank you everyone thank you to all the dragons
for being here 900k oh my god there's so many and there's so
many dragons i hope to hit a million 2020 like at the end of
2026 that's my goal i hope i can hit a million and then
after that i disappear i'm joking it's like after that's
like one million and then i never come back i'm joking i'm
like i will not disappear guys please then you'll be like
we'll never get you to a million so you'll stay with us
forever no guys i will not disappear guys i promise i won't
disappear the moment i hit
Let her reach 1 million.
No, no, it's a...
Guys, guys, I...
Yee-haha, guys.
Yee-haha.
Yeah, it sucks there at 999.
And, like, after 10 years, it's still 999,000.
Stop the count.
God, thank you for the super chat that you think.
Congrats on the 900k dokey.
Thank you.
Lithium, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you for being here with us.
Thank you.
Thank you, Lucita.
No, thank you guys for being here with me.
There's, like, like I said, many times I really wanted to
quit, and, like, I had, like, you know, breakdowns about
content creation, because it's hard.
Like, I know people are like, yeah, but it's not as hard as
a real job, but it's hard in its own way.
You know, um, it's hard in its own way, and still, I'm a
perfectionist when it comes to these things, and I always
want to do fun things with my dragon.
And so I always want to make you guys, you know, I don't
just want to play video games.
and um play video games and just like i feel like i'm always
what's the way i feel like i'm like slacking if i just do
that so i always want to do like fun things for you guys
like these types of streams and fun events and fun like
presents and projects for everyone i don't want to what's i
used to say a lot where i'm just it's not slacking but
what's that word i haven't used in a while I think I don't
believe her lies.
Just because I take a bribe doesn't mean that I'm corrupt.
No, that's coasting.
I don't want to coast.
I always want to help make lots of fun.
Yeah, I don't want to post.
I have been procrastinating a lot, though.
I think 2025 has been my most procrastinated year so far.
I think it's because I did so many events, too.
Because, like, events do tire me out a lot because I'm
talking a lot.
lot to a lot of people like um i'm like interacting a lot
too so events really do like take away a lot of my energy
but i still want to keep doing events and everything because
i want to meet as many dragons um one to one with as many
dragons as possible because um you know it's such a rare
opportunity to be able to have that and it's such a great
memory to have too like talking to you guys like you know
talking to your oshi talking to your fans and everything
it's always really fun and to be able to see to speak to you
in person to speak to you guys in person and have like a
personal conversation with all of you guys christ thank you
for the five gifted ships thank you thank you uh tom thank
you for the five gifted ships thank you thank you uh but
next see thank you the magenta soup but thank you thank you
thank you you're stuck with us for a good long time don't
you worry about that thanks for all the wonderful memories
don't you here's the many more thank you thank you the
magenta soup but thank you thank you uh guys thank you for
the super chat Thank you.
I'll keep supporting you as long as I can.
Keep on flying high.
Huge love.
Thank you.
The super chat.
Villainess and Krish.
Thank you.
Give me the gift of ships.
Solid snake.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for being the biggest gift.
Any of us dragoons could ever ask for.
You truly are a joy to spend time with new dragoons as well.
Congrats on 900k.
Here's some many more dragoons.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
By the way, I'm so hungry.
but my stomach was growling like in the last hour and I was
like oh my god I hope they don't hear my stomach growling I
like I've been working non-stop on this and the Christmas
stuff and next new year event like I swear I felt like I was
doing nine to five with overtime I would I I took up I slept
five hours today I mean five hours is better than like five
hours is actually pretty decent like i could have slept
three hours but um like i sent an alarm it was like three
hours actually i set up three hour alarm and i woke up and i
was like no like i was like i woke up i was like the alarm
woke me i was like no i said like two more hours i was like
okay i need this two hours no i have leftovers i left over
from yesterday so i'll heat that up after this stream um but
i felt like i was doing nine to five plus overtime the last
three days the last three days i've just been like working
non-stop for all the events and stuff it didn't really help
that i had this idea like literally this week like the
finalized idea of how i want to how i really want because
like i was like back and forth with so many things because i
was like i was like oh what do i how do i how do i just
debut a bunch of like cheapy skin suits like how do i do
that
This idea went through so many drafts leading up to my
finalized idea for this week When I say I did all this this
week, I meant my finalized plan I've been have other ideas I
had was like different from this idea But I kept like going
back and forth as to what I really wanted to do So so in the
end I settled to this one on this week because I was like no
I think this is the perfect way and then like I had the
whole image I've always wanted to do a the Doki verse even
when I was in Corpo like expand the verse but in Corpo I was
never able to able to like make that a reality because
there's a lot of rules and regulations for it like at best I
could only do PNGs and stuff so obviously that never came to
fruition because of it because I was just like oh PNGs are
just not not it's not as as like memorable I felt like
because it would be cool if we could actually if I could
actually move and everything and so I've had this idea in my
head about this whole universe in my head oh it'd be really
fun to do like play around with like building the lore and
everything because you can mess around with a lot of stuff
you know lots of like versions of your set lots of
creativity you can do with it like i remember like the
different like verses you can do it's always a multiverse is
always such a fun concept to play around with because you
can fuck around with a bunch of stuff because like it's not
your lore it's a different doke's lore you know like it's
like yeah like this happened to this doke like not the other
doke so i can like make a fucking dumbass lore for different
types of doke and i was like i want to be garfield and i'm
like yeah i'm dokefield from the garfield from the dokefield
universe like like yeah like shit like it's like i'm doki by
from like i'm not the like this is my doki verse yeah i'm
gonna surround as much as it's been like a fun concept
that's been rattling around my head so i hope you guys
enjoyed the expanded lore of the doki verse um that i made
up in this week i wrote the fucking script for three days
ago i literally had to look up model United Nations glossary
terms because I forgot how like meetings worked and I just
had like the basic I was like oh my god what do I call like
what do I call like when you use you like do the gavel and
stuff be like and I was like oh decorum oh my god yeah
decorum decorum delegates decorum I just try to remember how
council meetings work yeah because I used to do model UN so
I was like oh so I had like a basic knowledge of like um
yeah I used to be a fucking nerd I had like I used to do
model UN so I had like a general knowledge of how fucking
council meetings work and stuff uh so so I was like digging
through shit like that um back there thank you a super chat
thank you thank you oh you were in does I'm gonna keep
working hard to support you and your career.
We love you, Doug.
Congratulations on 900K.
Let's continue the journey to a 1 million.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
What happened to Nerd Duke?
She discovered gaming.
It was one or the other chat.
You know, you're like, you're upgrading your stats, and you
have to sacrifice some stats to go to the other.
Ever since I discovered competitive gaming, it went downhill
from there.
I took away the IQ points from my stats and put it all in
dexterity.
Ha ha ha.
Intellect, they...
I min-maxed.
I did a stat reset, yeah.
I dumped Intelligent for Dex.
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Look where that got you.
What do you mean?
We got Cheapy Prime.
But yeah, I will say again, thank you again for all the
support.
I guess I can't do all of this without you guys supporting
me, obviously.
because this is my job.
This is my income.
Like, this is literally my job.
So I couldn't do all these super fun streams, or I couldn't
keep doing all these projects and games because you guys
helped fund all of this for me and able to, you know, create
so many fun memories.
Like, yo-yo, you only live once.
So I want to create as many fun memories as I can before,
you know, it's all gone.
So I want to enjoy the experience.
Enjoy these dumb ideas that I have to make it into reality.
I said you guys help fund all of this like obviously like I
can't do this without you guys supporting me and um giving
me the like by either buying my merch by the way dokeymerch
.com um you guys want to help me get rid of my doggy shirts
please I know I keep talking about the doggy shirts but it
is a problem it
merch if you guys if you guys have a pet and who is who
wants to wear a very cool hawaiian shirt made for pets
please check out my merch uh diet they give them a gentle
suit but they can thank you um you could put it on a baby
but he has to wear pants he or she the baby has to wear
pants by the way uh because the shirt um i mean i mean it's
a shirt But you know what I mean.
You can put it on a baby or put it on your pet.
But, yeah, it works on dogs and cats.
But like I said, whether or not you're supporting me by
watching the stream, subscribing, donating, super chatting,
membering.
Members also help a lot, too, with the member funds and
everything.
Buying merch, it does help so much.
And let me do...
what I do.
And thank you.
Also, I want to say thank you for teaching me how to be an
adult too.
Because, you know, I was like very sheltered kid growing up.
And I was thrust into the adult world.
And now, yeah.
Try my best to live my life.
So thank you guys.
Thank you for being here with me on this journey.
um and whether you're an old dragon or a new dragon you're
always welcome in the dragon community I hope everyone has
made lots of new friends here um by just you know sharing a
common interest and like just playing together and hanging
out with each other and everything um and I guess off to
2026 we go let's hope we make Even more memories in 2026.
And let's go to 1 million.
1 million dollars.
I'm going to call it here, guys.
Me hungry.
I'm so hungry.
This has been the longest news segment ever.
From Dokiverse News, the DBN.
Doki Bird Network.
If anyone was wondering what DBN stands for.
Is Doki Bird Network, guys.
Being adult without preparing.
Good job, Doki.
Thank you.
the super chat to Corey thank you thank you yeah um I really
really appreciate it guys thank you everyone as always
everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around
and get that blood flowing and if you sit up with me head to
bed Because you deserve it.
Alright, I'll see you guys next time, everyone.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Let me get that gun out of the way.
Don't worry.
Your two dads are saying goodbye now.
Bye, everyone.
Bye.